FELIPE HOFFA: Hello.
I'm Felipe Hoffa at Google
Developer Relations.
And I help developers manage
and analyze their big data
as they could never
before, using Google Tools.
A few weeks ago, I received
a challenge via Twitter
from Graham Polley in Australia.
Check it out.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Hey, Felipe.
Possible requirement.
One table, 30 billion
rows, 30 terabytes of data.
No problem for BigQuery, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: 30
terabytes of data?
30 billion rows
in a single query?
My response was,
challenge accepted.
And well, turns out Graham
flew all the way from Australia
to our Mountain View studios
to take me up on my word.
Follow me to meet Luke
Alexander and Graham
Polley from Shine
Technologies where
we will learn, where did they
get this 30 terabytes of data?
What's the business
behind their project?
And how well the query
is working for them.
And of course, we'll
find out if the query
is up to the 30 terabytes,
30 billion rows challenge.
Let's find out right now.
Thank you for coming all
the way from Australia.
Graham Polley.
Luke Alexander.
Thank you for being here.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thanks for having us.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Really
excited to be here.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, I'm very
excited to have you too.
Let's get down to business.
Can you tell me what
is Shine Technologies?
What are you doing there?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah,
just Shine Technologies
we're an IT consultancy based
out of Melbourne, Australia.
We're about 55 developers.
And we work with most of
the major large corporates
in Australia, one
of which is Telstra,
what we're going to be
talking about today.
FELIPE HOFFA: Telstra.
That's where you're getting
your 30 terabytes of data?
LUKE ALEXANDER: That's right.
So Telstra is one of
Australia's largest ISP's.
And it's also a large
digital publisher.
And that's where we
get this data from.
We serve ads onto the
major digital properties.
And those ad impression logs
create a large volume of data.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
DoubleClick data?
LUKE ALEXANDER:
Yes, so this is all
served by Google DoubleClick.
And we process the
log files on the back
of those both impressions
and the clicks.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you're
getting a high amount
of clicks of impressions.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yes, we do.
2,000 requests a second at peak
plus clicks on top of that.
And that translates to
about 3 billion transactions
a month at peak.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
And how were you handling
this before knowing the query?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah, badly.
We had a lot of difficulty.
So we knew that there was a
real opportunity with the data
that we were seeing.
There was a lot of
data that was used
in those logs that we weren't
able to extract any other way.
So we used to try
and process them.
We'd have bash scripts,
which would cut up the logs,
throw away 90% of it, because
we could only handle about 10%
of volume.
We then split up the data, push
it into relational databases,
and try and use the
data from there.
But, you know, we blew up
disks, ran out of space,
saturated networks,
blew up table spaces,
got called in the
middle of the night.
GRAHAM POLLEY: I
didn't get called.
He got called.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah.
So it was hard work.
FELIPE HOFFA: But I think
everyone has felt that once.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
that was a year ago.
You had no idea that-- the
equipment was not on your map?
LUKE ALEXANDER: No,
so BigQuery came--
we came across BigQuery when
we moved to DoubleClick.
We found that by
default the log files
that we were receiving
from DoubleClick
were being written
to the Google Cloud.
So that made us have
a bit of a poke around
to see what we could do,
solve the BigQuery thing.
I thought this looks
like it could do the job.
Maybe this dream can come true.
And so we thought
we'd give it a try.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how was that?
How did you try--?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Well,
we took some real data.
It was fascinating.
We took some real data.
Graham and I sat down.
A cup of coffee.
Two hours later we'd
proven the problem.
The big problem was, can
we handle the volume?
And can we handle
the type of data?
We have some of the targeting
option from [? DFP ?] come
through in a large string
of key value pairs.
And we needed to
extract that data
and treat them all like columns.
That was a big challenge
for us, along with the data.
But within two hours, we had
a working copy of real data.
FELIPE HOFFA: So in two hours
you had your proof of concept.
That was all you needed.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
GRAHAM POLLEY: We
were just blown away.
We just sat there,
like Luke said.
And we just pulled in a
small data set first just
to see if we could extract that
data out, those three columns.
And then we pulled in a
month's worth of data.
And we just went Run, and
it just-- it blew us away.
LUKE ALEXANDER: It did.
It was amazing.
FELIPE HOFFA: Suddenly, you
were running regular expressions
over 2 billion records.
GRAHAM POLLEY: 2 billion.
Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: So with that,
you went to your client.
You told them--
LUKE ALEXANDER:
This is possible.
GRAHAM POLLEY: We can do this.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then it
translated into a real project.
You sold the project.
You have the--
LUKE ALEXANDER:
Yes, so then it was
a case of being able to
take that and produce
the reporting on the back of it.
The clients were really
excited about it.
They wanted to take
this as an offering back
to their advertisers.
There was some real great data
insights that we could provide.
And they were really
keen to see that this now
wasn't going to be a
massive IT project.
This is something that
they could actually
do with a small IT budget.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how
long did the project take?
LUKE ALEXANDER: So the
project took about six months.
Gathering requirements,
working out
what we were doing
with the data, how
we were going to
display, what data
we wanted to overlay on what.
And some of the normal
operational modes
of the data, how
we're processing it,
when we're processing it,
when we're cleaning it up
and those kinds of things.
FELIPE HOFFA: So what's so
great about-- what does Telstra
get from this?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yes, so the
key benefit that Telstra gets
is being able to tell
its advertisers what
are the people that
have seen those ads?
What are the demographics?
So we've got age, income,
the state that they're in,
the time of day that they're
in, that they saw their ad.
And we can overlay those
metrics against each other.
And we can really
show advertisers
who was seeing their ads,
who was responding to it,
was it meeting their
target demographics
that they were
trying to hit for?
And what are the things
they could possibly
try in the future?
Different targeting options.
Amazing stuff.
FELIPE HOFFA: So now you're
able to look at the data,
dice it, understand what
happened, who's clicking?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah and it's
a real end-user tool that
runs and returns in seconds
so the clients can generate
their own reports
as they want them.
And it's essentially
giving them large volumes
of data represented in nice
forms in the click of a button.
FELIPE HOFFA: They can
dig deeper on demand
wherever they want.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutey.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
And then you wrote a
blog post about this.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Right, so yeah.
One of the things working
at Shine Technologies
is that they
encouraged engineers
to talk about and write
about technologies that we're
working on, bleeding
edge technologies.
And I just found BigQuery
just blew me away.
And I wanted to write about
it so I put pen to paper
and wrote a blog post.
And I didn't really
think much of it.
I thought it was
a good blog post.
And I had some pretty
big numbers in there.
But it just gained
a bit of traction.
I think you picked it
up and you shared it.
FELIPE HOFFA: I remember
reading that blog post.
And I was like, on
one hand, amazing.
On the other hand, there
were some criticisms.
GRAHAM POLLEY: OK, it can't
be completely lopsided.
FELIPE HOFFA: Of course.
That was a very full review.
I guess you were very happy with
the latest news from the query.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
Yeah, so a couple of things with
the latest news as well-- so
we're getting a-- we found out
yesterday 100,000 streaming
inserts a second, which
is just phenomenal.
And also one of the things that
when we were writing our SQL
queries and refining those
SQL queries for this project,
we couldn't do multiple joins.
And we found that--
FELIPE HOFFA: You had to
do nested queries together?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, we
had to do nested queries.
Yeah, and that was a little
bit work around those nuances.
But fabulous news that we
can do it on there as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: That is great.
Now you have a Views tool.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Views,
[INAUDIBLE] table decorators.
And yeah it's phenomenal.
LUKE ALEXANDER: And the
85% pricing [INAUDIBLE]
is a big difference
to us as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah,
pricing that blew me off.
GRAHAM POLLEY: 85% is
just-- it's incredible.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you
wrote the blog post.
You won the traction.
Urs [INAUDIBLE]
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, right so
then after you had found it,
just a few days later I found
out that Urs Holzle had picked
it up and put it on
his Google+ page.
And he just shared it and said,
take a look at this blog post.
It's a good read.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's amazing.
You've been giving talks now.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Yeah, we got invited
myself and another engineer.
We got invited then to do a
few talks around Melbourne,
which have gone really well.
And we've got another few
in the pipeline as well.
So it's phenomenal.
We weren't expecting
that from the blog post.
It was really cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now what
I want to know now
is how you're using the query.
Can you show us?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
What we tend to do
is we work with small
data sets first.
And that allows us
then to refine our SQL
and get it into a
state that we're
happy with to push to
production and then really start
working on big data sets.
But we start small first.
And of course that keeps
our costs down as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
a good pattern.
Develop your queries
on small data,
then scale it up as
much as you need.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Exactly, yeah.
It's great as well.
So we're just running over
maybe a few megabytes even
just or a few 100,000 rows.
And the responses are
coming back in seconds.
So it just allows us that rapid
way of getting [? truancy ?]
and building our
SQL into that state.
It's phenomenal.
That's the way we go.
So what I want to
show you is actually--
this is one of our
production queries.
And it's not an overly
complex SQL query.
It's actually quite
straightforward.
We've got a few [? nested ?]
[? selects. ?] We're pulling
out our core columns that we
want from the raw data tables.
And what I really want
to focus on though
is the regular
expressions down here.
So what we touched on earlier,
this is core to this project.
This was-- we have to
have this in there.
And BigQuery gave
us that ability
to be able to go to that
one column and slice
and dice it up and pull at
those values that we needed.
And that's what you can
see here in the SQL.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you're taking
all of this custom variables
transforming them into columns?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
Yeah.
And I've got some joins here.
And then we're just doing
an aggregation on that.
We're just grouping
by all those columns.
And we're just building
these summary tables up,
which are then given
to the front end
for the visualization.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's try it.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Absolutely.
So this is the query.
It's ready to run.
You can see here in
BigQuery's validation bar.
We're about to
process 6.04 megs.
So we'll just hit six megs.
And it's about 47,000 rows.
So this is actually
a good window
into how we work with BigQuery,
working on the small data sets
and then gradually ramping up.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's nothing.
Any database can do that.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: But we
can run our queries.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Absolutely.
I'm gonna pull the trigger.
FELIPE HOFFA: Pull the trigger.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So this
should just take-- literally,
we're going over 40
something thousand rows.
It's 3.6 seconds.
It's a cost of zero
cent which is just--
FELIPE HOFFA: You're using
the Street plug in there.
I can see.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
that's-- you spotted that.
I'm impressed.
Yeah, yeah.
That's cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, Streetcar
is very good friends of us.
We did a video recently.
Check it out.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
the Street plug in just
gives a few little
niceties to the web UI.
So I like to use it.
And you get the cost in there.
And you're able to--
FELIPE HOFFA: So now you
have your aggregations.
You have your new columns.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, exactly.
So these are our
summary-- in essence,
these are our summary tables.
Now these result sets that
you can see at the bottom
here are our summary tables.
And you can see, we do
have a few nulls in there
but we leave them out of the
summary tables in the end.
Then we've got our
values coming out.
And these are the values
actually coming out
of those regular expressions.
And then we're
remapping them and doing
some aggregation on those.
FELIPE HOFFA: But this was only
over six megabytes of data.
How do you scale this up?
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
what we do then
is after we're happy with the
SQL and we know it's working,
we then ramp it up to about
a month's worth of data.
And that month's worth of
data is about 2 billion rows
or above.
In some cases we've got
2.53 to 3 billion rows.
And then we're up in
big data territory.
So we're going from 500 gig
to 750 up to a terabyte.
And that's when it starts
getting interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's try it out.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So I've
got this query here.
It's the exact same query that
I've just walked you through
and shown you.
But it's just pointing
to a bigger table.
So it's pointing to our raw,
one month's worth of data.
And that data is about
2.2 billion rows.
FELIPE HOFFA: 2.2 billion rows?
GRAHAM POLLEY: 2.2 billion rows.
And I believe this
table is somewhere
in the region of about 3/4
of a terabyte to a terabyte.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we're
only going here over--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yes, so
we're-- yeah, correct.
So what you've spotted is
BigQuery is smart enough.
It says, well
actually, I don't need
to go over everything
in the data set.
I only need to go
over the columns
that you actually want me
to work on in your SQL.
And I'm actually only
going to query-- or sorry,
I'm only going to
process 159 gig.
So that's just great as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's run it.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Let's.
So just to put this
in perspective,
2.2 billion rows, 159 gig.
FELIPE HOFFA: This was
impossible for you a year ago?
GRAHAM POLLEY: We couldn't
do this in the past.
OK, so we can see the
queries running here
and then it's going over
a serious amount of data.
So I estimate that's going
to take about somewhere
in the region-- what we've
seen in our log files
takes about 25 to 30 seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you run
these queries every day?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
We've got an automation
built into all this.
And we're actually running
22 of these queries
nightly on our data, because
we have multiple summary tables
and multiple aggregation tables
for the front end to work with.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
with those tables,
you're able to present the
data interactively later.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
So here you go.
Here's our results.
You can see that it
took exactly 38 seconds.
It processed 159 gig, which
the validator said it would.
And it came at a cost
of 556 cents to us.
FELIPE HOFFA: And that's
the previous cost.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, prices have
been going down a lot now.
GRAHAM POLLEY: 85%.
FELIPE HOFFA: 85% now.
Well, pretty convenient for you.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
That's going to save
us quite a bit of money
and our clients
some money, yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's cool.
And what do you
do with this data?
How do you transform
this summary table in--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
So what we do now is that
data and those summary tables,
they're given to the front end.
And the front end is now going
to query those tables using
the BigQuery API, the RESTful
API over at JavaScript web app.
FELIPE HOFFA: Show me.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Absolutely.
I'd love to show you.
So this is the front end.
I'm just going to run the
report on the basic demographics
that we have, or the ones
that we just pulled out,
which is gender, location, age,
income and hour of the day.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this
is a JavaScript app
that is loading
data from the query?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
And you can see that
it's still pretty quick.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you're able
to choose all the dimensions?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah.
So this is giving real
insights into the data
for our customers.
So we're getting breakdowns
about impressions by gender,
rolling down into the location
so the states within Australia.
FELIPE HOFFA: Look
at Australia there.
LUKE ALEXANDER:
Yeah, absolutely.
And you can see here that
the impressions are pretty
much in line with
population or thereabouts,
so nothing unbelievable
insights in there.
FELIPE HOFFA: Makes sense.
What else?
LUKE ALEXANDER: What
else have we got?
Moving down, we've got age.
So the various
different impressions
for the different age
groups and the trend
of the different click-through
rates for the different ages.
Further along, household income.
And then hour of day.
Hour of day's got some
interesting information here.
So what we can see is a pretty
consistent set of impressions.
So the blue line is pretty
consistent over the period
of time.
And we see that red line
increasing as the hour of day
goes on, showing that for
some reason, around 4 o'clock,
3 or 4 o'clock, we start to
see more clicks on ads than we
do at 10 o'clock in the morning.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
when I finally-- you
are able to
understand-- Telstra is
able to understand
what is happening.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah, and we
can provide the information back
to the advertisers and agencies.
And they get some real insight
into how the targeting's
working, what other targeting
options they could be using.
Yeah and just information that
they just never had before.
FELIPE HOFFA: And they
have an interactive app
where they can go
further down the--
LUKE ALEXANDER: They can
run it whenever they want.
It takes seconds to come back.
It's the whole picture.
FELIPE HOFFA: Perfect.
I love it.
This is your application.
We're doing what you
could never do before.
But you a challenge for me.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah,
so on the back of this
we got really excited.
This is something we
had never done before.
But once Graham had
written the blog
and the conversation had
started, I wanted to go bigger.
I wanted a year's worth of data.
If we can do it for a month,
can't we do it for a year?
And this is where it started.
So Graham then decided to
pass that challenge on.
FELIPE HOFFA: And that's when
you decided to send the tweet.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah,
the tweet was sent.
And the challenge was set.
FELIPE HOFFA: You
loaded all the data.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Exactly, yeah.
So we laid down the gauntlet
to you and to BigQuery,
because we really
wanted to see, could it
handle a year's worth of data?
Could it handle 30 terabytes?
FELIPE HOFFA: How fast
were you loading this data?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yes, so
a month's worth of data
takes about--
actually, it doesn't
take-- it takes 28 seconds.
I did it-- I timed it for one
of the months and that was,
I think, 2 billion
rows in 28 seconds
from Google Cloud storage
straight into BigQuery.
So it took a few hours to get a
year's worth of data in there.
But we--
FELIPE HOFFA:
Sounds pretty good.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
it's pretty quick.
We're pretty happy with it.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we're running
the same query, the same query
over 6 megabytes of data,
over 230 megabytes of data.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Shall we do it?
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's do it.
GRAHAM POLLEY: You excited?
FELIPE HOFFA: Show me.
GRAHAM POLLEY: OK.
So we're going to
ramp this up now.
We're going from
six to a few 100 gig
and then we're going
up to 6.24 terabytes.
FELIPE HOFFA: 6.4 terabytes?
Why is it 6.4 terabytes?
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
it's 6.24 terabytes
because, of course, BigQuery
like we touched on earlier
is smart enough to work
out that the query itself
isn't going over the whole data
set, which is 30 terabytes.
And it just needs to pull at
those columns that we need.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh,
that's perfect.
Very cool.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So it's
still a huge amount of data.
And it's 36.6 billion rows
that we're about to query.
FELIPE HOFFA: 36.6 billion rows.
Will it run?
GRAHAM POLLEY: I hope so.
FELIPE HOFFA: You
can do the honors.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thank you so much.
I'm really excited.
FELIPE HOFFA: And it's running.
I think it will take
more than 30 seconds.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
I'd imagine it's
going to take a few minutes to
run, which is still phenomenal.
FELIPE HOFFA: How are you
using the web interface?
Tell me more about--
LUKE ALEXANDER: So
the web interface
is used by our agencies
and advertisers
to be able to use those
graphs in presentations
that they provide back to
their customers and advertisers
in reports and
things that they use.
I think some of the other
things that we talk about here
is that we've learned
a lot by using BigQuery
and we've had a lot of practice.
We created a lot of
data in the first place.
And we created a large mess.
And we needed to learn to
clean up after ourselves.
So a lot of this has
been we've introduced
things like automated
cleanups, closing down
tables when we're not
using them anymore,
but also we're using
the dashboard in a--
of the BigQuery
interfaces a dashboard
for our operations team.
So we feed our logs of
the success of the loads
back into the tools
so our operations
guys can check those logs,
check the size of the files that
were processed,
look for anomalies.
And it becomes our day to day
dashboard of data, really.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you're
using the query not only
to analyze all this
data, you're using
it to analyze your operations.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Operations.
Yeah, absolutely.
And then obviously
on top of that
we've got that data in there.
So quite often now when
the business come and go,
I'd really like to know
how many people over 65
have been to site X between
the hours of 2:00 and 4:00.
And it's things that we
could never answer before.
But the product people
really need that information
for pricing purposes.
We can now do that.
We just run an ad hoc query,
using the web interface,
and we've got the
results in seconds.
So it created a whole new
set of opportunities for us.
FELIPE HOFFA: And now you
have all the new features.
You have the [INAUDIBLE]
actions streaming.
I want to see what
you can do with that.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah, we've
got some big [INAUDIBLE]
streaming already.
So web streaming at
only 1,000 requests
a second, it was a
bit limiting for us.
But with the announcements
yesterday that's
opened a whole new world
of possibilities to us.
FELIPE HOFFA: 100,000
rows per second?
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
So this is even
with the challenge
of the big 36 billion rows, what
this has led us to understand
is, how much data we've
got, how valuable that is.
And we're even now
looking with the business
about the different contexts in
which that data could be used.
Now with the price
drops as well,
this makes it even
more appealing.
We can run more data,
look for more insights
across more demands.
So we're looking outside
of just ad serving.
Now, we're looking at being
able to use this data in many
of the contexts within Telstra.
FELIPE HOFFA: I like it.
You will bring it
to other clients.
LUKE ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Definitely.
FELIPE HOFFA: We still have
the query running here.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
it's still going.
Yeah, we've got to bear in mind.
It's crunching a serious
amount of data here.
FELIPE HOFFA: I know.
We're running over
seven terabytes of data.
We're running a
regular expression.
We are grouping.
We are using
distributive grouping.
We are shelving it as--
LUKE ALEXANDER: Well,
I presume you are.
We don't have to
worry about that.
That's the great thing.
And another of the big things
that we found with this as well
was with its SQL-like interface,
it just created a massive--
it brought down that
barrier to entry.
We could get going on this
without necessarily knowing
about the underlying
technology that's
having to be in place to run it.
We're not having to worry about
the log files and the disks
that they're stored on.
We're not having to worry
about who's cleaning those up,
how much-- other than
how much it costs us
when the data is in there.
All that headache and
problem that we'd had
before has gone away.
And--
FELIPE HOFFA: You're
not going back
to your previous [INAUDIBLE]
LUKE ALEXANDER: That's
never going back.
FELIPE HOFFA: How's it running?
GRAHAM POLLEY: So we're
up at 230 seconds now.
I've got a feeling it's
getting close now, to the end.
FELIPE HOFFA: Have you
run this query before?
GRAHAM POLLEY: There
was a point in time
a few weeks ago when
I was getting prepared
that we did have
some data in there.
And I just couldn't
resist having a look
and running the query.
But I only did it over
a smaller data set.
I didn't do it on
this volume of data.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well,
let's wait and see.
Any parting points?
LUKE ALEXANDER: No, I mean,
the announcements yesterday
across the cloud board were
for me really exciting to hear.
It's really stepping
up the opportunities
for BigQuery and the
other Google products
into the enterprise market
where we do most of our work.
And our clients have been
really interested to see
what we can do with the
technologies on offer now.
FELIPE HOFFA: You
were-- you were featured
in the "Wall Street
Journal" yesterday, too.
LUKE ALEXANDER: We managed
to get a line in there.
When the "Wall
Street" journalist
was trying to quantify what
the price difference was
and how that compared to other
offerings in the marketplace,
we were able to give them a real
world example of our 36 billion
row query, which was
going to cost us $248
and now would cost
us less than $40.
So we were able to give him
that real world example.
And he was kind
enough to publish it.
FELIPE HOFFA: We are at--
GRAHAM POLLEY: At 320 seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
about five minutes.
And it's still running.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And
it's still going.
FELIPE HOFFA: Should
we go to a rec?
Should we wait
until it finishes?
MALE SPEAKER: Up to you guys.
It's a--
FELIPE HOFFA: It finished!
GRAHAM POLLEY: All right.
So we just processed 6.24
terabytes in 334 seconds.
So BigQuery did its job.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yay!
GRAHAM POLLEY: High five.
LUKE ALEXANDER: That's exciting.
GRAHAM POLLEY: That's awesome.
That's--
FELIPE HOFFA: We went
over the big, big table.
30 billion rows.
We can now see a
whole year of data.
GRAHAM POLLEY: This is a
whole year of data, yep.
So this is, of course,
the aggregation table
here in its raw format
inside the query.
So what I can do is
I can flip back over.
And maybe we can
have a look at what
insights that data is now
giving us over a year.
So I'm just going to knock off
the other ones, which I'm just
going to take these two graphs.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you're
running the same app now
over a year of data you are
able to see-- Going over
a month was a dream.
Going over a year
was impossible.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
This is new for us.
This is--
LUKE ALEXANDER: Yeah,
opened up new possibilities.
So we started to look
at what insights could
we get about our data
over an entire year.
We've got some train
graphs here showing
our male and female viewers
across the different sites
across our entire network.
And we see that during
the Australian sporting
season around
February, March time,
we start to ramp up the
number of male users.
But female users keeps
kind of constant.
And back at the end
of the football season
that user base declines.
FELIPE HOFFA: This is awesome.
I love those graphs.
Thank you very much, Graham.
Thank you very much, Luke.
I hope to see you again.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thank you, Felipe.
LUKE ALEXANDER:
Thanks very much.
FELIPE HOFFA: The [INAUDIBLE].
Everything worked out.
I'm so happy.
This is awesome.
Please, stay curious.